ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนะเรียนทุกคนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะผู้
หญิงคะวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
เสาร์ค่ะอ๋อวันนี้วันเสาร์วันที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันที่ 14 ค่ะวันที่ 14 นะคะเดือนอะไร
คะ
เดือน
พฤษภาคมเดือนพฤษภาคมปี
2 เท่าไหร่คะดีผช
2565 ค่ะแล้วปีคศเท่าไหร่คะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงมีวงคะตอนนี้
เวลา
04:54 นาทีค่ะ
04:54 นาทีนะคะไปค่ะครูเอ๋
คลิปนี้
เอกก็ยังแข็งแรงค่ะผู้หญิงไม่ท้องทั้งกู
เองบอกตัวเองบอกจะแข็งแรงตัวเองแข็งแรง
นักเรียนของเราเนี่ยแข็งแรงแล้วก็มาทุกคน
ไหมคะ
มากครบค่ะอ๋อครูเอ๋
ผู้หญิงเช็คชื่อคุยใช่ไหม
กูเอ๋ทำได้ค่ะคุณ John คุณป้าคุณเคล้าคุณ
ลิซ่าคุณประวีณา
คุณธาราชิคุณแพ
ดีนะอ่า
คุณอะไรนะคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณแร้ค
ทำไมเหลือ 9 คนคุณส่าถ้าคะคุณสหราชอาคุณ
โอ๋โอ๊ะๆ
สองคนเห็นวะโอเค
ตัวเองเก่งว่ะไม่ใช่ผู้หญิงอ่ะไม่ได้ไม่
ได้เช็คครูเอ๋ครูหญิงจะบอกครูเอว่าคลิป
ที่แล้วเนี่ยนักเรียนดู
ว่าที่บ้านครูเอ๋เอ๋บ้านครูหญิงเนี่ยมี
เฟอร์นิเจอร์อะไรบ้างดูภาพใช่มั้ยคะใช่ๆ
ใส่ค่ะดูภาพเนาะรูปภาพเราเรียกว่าภาพ
ค่ายเสบียงนอนนะคะ
ภาพตู้เสื้อผ้าๆแต่ภาพนี้น่ะค่ะครูเอ๋
แล้วผู้หญิงวาดผม
ขอสีขาวเนาะค่ะ
นี่แหละค่ะความนี้ภาพอะไรคะครูเอ๋โต๊ะทำ
งานค่ะใต้ภาพโต๊ะทำงานนักเรียนเนี่ยดูภาพ
โต๊ะทำงานไปแล้วค่ะอู้โต๊ะนี้สวยนะทรายสี
ม่วงใช่ไหมคะ
ไม่ว่างๆบ่โต๊ะมีขาเนี่ยขาโต๊ะอาหาตัวเอง
ช่วยว่าขาโต๊ะเนี่ยสี่ขานะคะแล้วก็บนโต๊ะ
เนี่ยเอาข้าวโต๊ะมีหนึ่งสองสามสี่ขาโต๊ะ
เนี่ยสี่ขาเราก็ตอนนี้เป็นโต๊ะใช่ไหมคะคน
บนโต๊ะเนี่ยไม่มีอะไรอ่ะจะเก็บเจ็บๆว่าอู
เอ
โอเอ 2 ครั้งแล้วใช่ไหมคะวันนี้อยู่ไอ้ 1
เครื่องคู่ฟ้า
เจ็บ
เจ็บต้องเรียนต้องให้ชนที่ขอบโต๊ะตรง
เนี้ยตรงไหนคะขอบโต๊ะอา
ขอบโต๊ะ f
ข้อสอบกับตรงนี้ของตัวเอนอ่ะข้อสอบแล้วก็
แขนตัวนี้ชนขอ
ขอบโต๊ะค่ะเจ็บเจ็บนะอ้าวผู้หญิงทำไมให้
ครูเอ๋ดูโต๊ะทำงานเอ้าก็ครูบอกว่าบนโต๊ะ
ทำงานเนี่ยว่างไหมในรูปภาพนะคะแต่โต๊ะทำ
ไม่มีอะไรไม่มีไม่มีแต่โต๊ะทำงานครูหญิง
โต๊ะทำงานครูเอ๋เนี่ยไม่ว่างใช่ไม่ว่าง
ถ้า
มีของมากๆ
เยอะมาก
โหก็วันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงก็เลยจะมาถามครู
เอ๋ว่าว่าบนโต๊ะทำงานนะบนโต๊ะทำงานครูเอ๋
มีอะไรบ้างแต่ก็บนโต๊ะทำงานครูหญิงมีอะไร
บ้างผู้หญิงอยากจะดูหรือว่ารูปคะ
ครูเอ๋อยากวาดรูปหรือดูคะสองอย่างได้ไหม
ได้ๆงั้นเดี๋ยวขอคุยกลับไปที่หน้าให้กู
อีกว่ารูปได้ก่อนนะถ้า
แค่กูเห็นลบก่อนนะคะลบได้ลบลบๆลบก่อนอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวกูเองหยิบก่อนก็ได้ค่ะว่าบนโต๊ะครู
เอ๋มีอะไรบ้าง
Green ก่อนก็ได้คู๋โอเคค่ะแต่ผู้หญิงที่
โต๊ะทำงานกูหญิงนะอย่างที่ 1 มีอะไรคะ
คอมพิวเตอร์ค่ะ
นักเรียนสระไม่เห็นนะคะ
ว่าผู้หญิงนักเรียนเข้าใจคอมพิวเตอร์
ไม่เข้าใจหนูไม่มีอะไรเข้าใจไหมคะนี่
คอมพิวเตอร์
ชนิดนั้นเลยบอกว่าวาดรูปแล้วไม่เข้าใจเลย
ผู้หญิงป๋านักเรียนเข้าใจวาดรูปเสร็จให้
เป็นคิดวันที่นอนไม่ช่วยคอมพิวเตอร์ไงเรา
ก็ตรงนี้ก็มีเมาส์
มีสายด้วยสายสายไฟใส่ค่ะมีสายเมาส์
ออใส่ Mouth
อ๋อ
มีรูเองด้วยคูเอหมายถึงสายชาร์จ
คอมพิวเตอร์โอ๊ยน่อห่านี่ค่ะนี่สายชาร์จ
คอมพิวเตอร์ของครูหญิงทั้งนี้มีอีกไม่
เสียบคะเดี๋ยวเสียบดึงออกมาให้ตัวเองดู
เฉยๆค่ะร้อนๆนะตอนเหมือนกันบนโต๊ะทำงาน
ครูหญิงและมีคอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็มีเหมาถาม
ว่าใช้ด้วยกัน
ครูเอกก็มีคอมพิวเตอร์ครับครูหญิงขอดู
พร้อมพิวเตอร์ครูเอ๋ได้ไหมคะขอดูได้ค่ะอะ
ครูเอ๋โกเอ๋มีกล้อง
เองโอ้โอโอ้โหแล้วก็ดูผู้หญิงมีผู้หญิง
ด้วยให้ผู้หญิงเยอะจังเลยอยู่ในนั้น
เห็นว่าไว้อ่ะอันนี้กูเองอะไรคะ
kuai ไม่ได้ใช้กล้องคอมพิวเตอร์เหรอคะ
พี่อ๋อค่ะๆๆถ้าคุยเปิด
ครูเอ๋ไม่ได้ใช้กล้องที่คอมพิวเตอร์ผู้
หญิงอยากเห็นกล้องที่คอมพิวเตอร์ไหมคะแนว
นี้เดี๋ยวกู a ให้ดูยังไงคะครูเอ๋สักครู
นะคะ
แต่กล้องคอมพิวเตอร์อยู่ข้างล่างขอ
ล่างคู่เอกก็เลยต้องมีกล้องเป้อันนี้
เรียกกล้องอะไรคะเว็ปแคมเหรอคู๋
ที่อยู่ในคอมพิวเตอร์เป็นเว็บแคมตอนนี้
เป็นกล้องอาย f  f
a
มันเกิดจากรู้จักคำว่าอุ้ยตลอดนะคะ
f แล้วก็ Case  B อ๋อ
เมื่อเสียบแล้วก็
Witch ตกใจๆ
หอมอยู่ข้างบนคอมใช้วางไว้ตรงนี้อยู่บน
คอมเดี๋ยวข้างบนนะคะอ่ะครูเอ๋ใช้ต้อง
กล้องที่คอมพิวเตอร์ไม่ชัดชายไม่เวลาดู
แบบเหมือนเบลอๆนิดหน่อยใช่เอกลมหน้าตลอด
มันอยู่ตรงแม่อยู่ข้างล่างข้างล่างน่ะ
ข้างล่างข้างล่างอะค่ะกินข้างล่าง
เปลี่ยนกล้องนะคะ
เออตัวเองสวยมาก
คอมพิวเตอร์ครูเอกกล้องไม่สวยต้องซื้อ
กล้องใหม่คะอันนี้เป็นของขวัญ
โน้นก็มีมีอะไรนะเป็น
ก็มีมิกล่องละฮะ
แล้วก็กล้องอยู่ข้างใน
แต่ตอนนี่มีริบบิ้นค่ะ
ใช่มั้ย 1
มกราคมใช่ไหมอ๋อของขวัญปีใหม่ค่ะใช่นัก
เรียน writing ฉงครูของขวัญปีใหม่ขอนัก
เรียนอยากเห็นครูสวยๆชัดๆๆ
มองไม่เห็น
นักเรียนรู้ครูไม่เข้าใจเทคโนโลยี
ตอนนี้ไมโครโฟนโอเคไหมคะยังไม่มีของขวัญ
ไมโครโฟนแต่ถ้านักเรียนอยากให้ไมโครโฟน
โอเคก็ของขวัญได้
หน้าหาก็หลอนๆก็พูดของขวัญแล้วร้อนฟรีไม่
ดีนะคะร้อน
ขอบคุณค่ะอ่า
นะคะเอมี่เข้าใจค่ะ
อุ้ย
อภิสิทธิ์คิดเอาเองเดี๋ยวร้อนเนี่ยออก
เดี๋ยวผู้หญิงบอกก่อนก็ได้อีกอย่างนึงจี้
บนโต๊ะของทำงานครูหญิงนี้มี
อะไรคะเชิญค่ะฉันเนี้ยไอ้หนิงพูดได้ใช่
ไหมคะคุณเอ๋มีจอได้
มีไฟค่ะครูเอ๋ไม่ได้อยู่ไม่ได้อยู่ข้างบน
ของนะอยู่ข้างหลังข้างหลังคอม
จะนะผู้หญิงคู๋ปุ๊ป
เฮ้ยมีไฟอันนี้หรือไปผู้หญิงก็มีค่ะกู a
แต่ของดีแล้วไม่เวิร์คเลยค่ะทำไมอ่ะคะ
เพราะว่าห้องครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่เหมือนห้อง
ครูเอ๋ไงพี่ต้องใช้ไฟสว่างมากๆอันนี้
สว่างไม่พอเจ็บตาไม่ผู้หญิง
นิดหน่อยอ่ะแต่กูหญิงจะเปิดเวลาที่อัด
วีดีโอเท่านั้นตอนนี้เปิดไหมคะเปิดค่ะอัน
นี้เปิดแล้วเราเปิดแล้วค่ะครูเอ๋ขอกูเอง
ไม่เลยแล้วเปิดแล้วยังไม่สว่างเลยอ่ะ
ครูเอ๋จะเปิดไฟตอน
Way อยากดูผู้หญิงปิดมั้ยล่ะคะได้ค่ะผู้
หญิงปิดไฟผู้หญิงปิด
โอ้โหโอเค
คุยทั้งวันไงผู้หญิงเช็คที่สุ่มซูมเพิ่ม
สว่างได้เอาแล้วแต่ว่ามันมันไม่ค่อยสว่าง
มากนะคะคุยดูนะของมีเฮนะคะนักเรียนถ้าครู
เอ๋
ที่สูบอันนี้จะมืดค่ะมืดนะฮะแล้วก็คือ
ระหว่าง
เดี๋ยวคุยกันก็เลยต้องไม่ต้องเปิดไฟ
ถ้า
ผ้าตอน 8:00 น
อ่ะโอเคเปิดเปิดไฟอ้าวตอนเว็บเปิดไฟตอน
กลางคืนค่ะผู้หญิงเนี่ยกลางวันเปิดไฟกลาง
คืนเปิดไฟ
โอเค
วิ่งปุ้ยผู้หญิงมีไฟที่โต๊ะทำงานครูเอกก็
มี
กี่โต๊ะกี่โต๊ะแล้วครูเอมีอะไรอีกคะที่
โต๊ะทำงานเมื่อกี้คุณหญิงบอกมีเมาส์ใช่
ไหมค่ะมีเรามีสาย 4 คู่เอกก็มีเม้าส์แล้ว
เมาคู๋มีสายไหมไม่มีสายครูเอ๋มีเมาส์ไร้
สายเหรอคะได้เมาส์ไร้สาย
นี้เอ๋ทำไมท้ายเทคโนโลยีมากเลยฟรีกับ
คอมพิวเตอร์ขอ
อีกอันนี้คอมพิวเตอร์ผู้หญิงมั้งฟรีใช่
ไหมฟรีไซส์ค่ะผู้หญิงคู๋มีอย่างอื่นอีก
ที่โต๊ะทำงานรู้ A มีอะไรอีกคะที่โต๊ะทำ
งานเดี๋ยวนะเอามาให้ดูเลยเยอะมาก
อะไรคะครูเอ๋ปิดขโมยของสามีไง
ถุง
เป๊ะเอาของสามี
อะไรคะคลิปแมะ
คลิปนิคเลข 10 ใช่ค่ะคลิปนี้ใช้กระดาษถูก
แล้วค่ะนั้นลวดเสียบ
ไมค์แล้วพูดคลิปคลิปเนาะคลิป
คลิปๆเวลามีกระดาษขายกระดาษแต่ก็กระดาษจะ
ไว้ด้วยกันก็
เมด
แหนบกระดาษที่โต๊ะเก๋มีคลิปเหน็บกระดาษมา
ค้าฤทธิ์ครูเอ๋ตัวใหญ่มากนะคะใช่ค่ะ
นี่ค่ะผู้หญิงมีอะไรที่ตกทำงานผู้หญิงมี
เขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะคะอะไรคะกล่องใส่ดินสอ
จ้าเขาโทรหากล่องปากกามั้ยวิ่งก็มีปากกา
แล้วก็มีกล่องแล้วก็วางตัดกาดใส่ปากกาพระ
เอกก็มีค่ะอุณหภูหูกูเห็นมีปากกาเยอะมากๆ
ค่ะแต่ไม่ใช้อ้าขอ
ฝันเปล่าไว้
เยอะมากแต่ไม่ใช้มันเหม็น
เหมือนกันค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยโต๊ะ
ทำงานครูหญิงเนี่ยก็มีไวท์บอร์ดค่ะนั้นมี
ไวท์บอร์ดแล้วก็มีปัดกาไวท์บอร์ดแต่ว่า
เวลาเขียนแล้วมันเหม็นอ๋อใช่ไหมจมูกไม่
โอเคไวท์บอร์ดมันมีทินเนอร์ฉันแล้วก็มี
นิปุณได้ค่ะคุณเอ๋ฝุ่นไม่ก็เลยไม่ใช้แล้ว
ไวท์บอร์ดที่คอมพิวเตอร์โอเคใส่ค่ะขอบคุณ
ซูมใส่ค่ะนี่ไวท์บอร์ด iPad
กูอ่ะมีอันนี้นะคะอ้าพร้อมกันเลยนะฮะอะไร
คะครูเอ๋
คนไทยเรียกว่าแม็กซ์
ใช่สั้นๆเมื่อผู้หญิงมีหนึ่งอีกใช่ไหม
บีกินเนอร์ศูนย์ของเรา
แล้วเหรอมีมีกระดาษนะคะมีมีมีกระดาษแล้ว
ก็มี
เขียนแล้วก็อันนี้เสื้อ
เอกจะเอาแม็กเนี่ย
แม็กซ์
มีนักเรียน
คอมเมนต์หรอ
ยุแม็กกระดาษที่เสื้อ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ครูเอ๋ทำแล้วก็พูดเหมือนกันให้นักเรียนดู
แล้วก็ฟังอิเมื่อ
ผู้หญิงมีแม็กไหมคะไม่มีค่ะอีกไม่มีอีก
กล่องใส่ปากกาเนี่ยไม่มี Bag จะมีปากกา
commy ปัดการตคำผิด
แต่ว่าครูเอ๋บนโต๊ะทำงานครูหญิงเนี่ยมี
ไอแพดค่ะน้องจะไปแฟลตใช่มั้ยรูปเดียวกับ
พี่ผู้หญิงวะ
ออก
ทำไมครูหญิงว่าสวยมีไอแพดแล้วก็มีปากกา
ไม้ปากกา iPad เอาไว้วาด
อุ้ย kuai ไม่มีไอแพดบนโต๊ะทำงานแต่กูเอ
มีอันนี้
มีอะไรคะครูเอ๋
อันนี้ค่ะ iPad ผู้หญิงวางที่นี่ iPad
วางอยู่ข้างหน้าคอมพิวเตอร์ไฟอยู่ข้าง
หลังคอมพิวเตอร์
The  Grey มีอะไรอีกนะคะที่โต๊ะทำงานบน
โต๊ะทำงานมีที่วางเมาส์
หงอแล้วก็เรียกมาเอาเนาะว่าเขาเรียกเมาส์
ผู้หญิงไม่มีที่วางเมาส์ค่ะกูอีกทำไม
ผู้หญิงวางเมาส์บนโต๊ะทำงานเลยขอครูเอ๋มี
ที่วางเมาส์
เมาส์วางบนที่วางเมาส์ขา R มีที่วางเมาส์
แล้วก็เอาเมาส์วางบนที่วางเมาค่ะคุยมีอัน
นี้มีอะไรคะ
ห๊าหรอ
ปากกาวาด
ว่าที่คอมพิวเตอร์โอโห้
ขอบคุณคอมพิวเตอร์ไม่ใช่รูหญิงมีปากกา
ปากกากาวปากกาอะไรคะอากาวที่เขียนกับสมุด
อะมีทั้งหมดก็มีปากกาผู้หญิงเขียนอะไร
เยอะๆเพราะจิตแขนตัวเอง
คู๋เขียนในคอมพิวเตอร์
ร้านครั้งคุยขี้เกียจเขียนที่คอมพิวเตอร์
ก็คิด
ดูวีดีโอดู YouTube คิดถ้าปิดก็เขียนที่
สมุดก็อยู่บนโต๊ะทำงานค่ะครูเอ๋เขียนที่
สมุดดีกว่าเนาะตาย ami อีกผู้หญิงมีอะไร
อีกคะบนโต๊ะทำงานสวยคะอะไรอ่ะ
กูเอาไว้ทำงานเหรอคะไว้สอนภาษาไทยเหรอคะ
ค่อยสอนภาษาไทยได้ไหมนี่คืออะไรคะเวลาที่
ครูเอ๋สอนเสร็จแล้วครูเอกก็ต้องหาใช่ไหม
ถ้าปิดอะไรหาๆเหนื่อยกูเอกก็หยิบอันนี้
ขึ้นมาแล้วก็
เอาไว้เก่าหัวเหรอคู๋ไว้หนูอ้วนขอไว้นวด
นวดนวดนี้ก็ไว้นวด
ไว้นวดหัว
ใช่ไวนวดกูสบายๆอันนี้มีสองสามสี่ห้า
เหมือนนิ้ว 1  2  3  4  5 วันนี้วิ่งหนี
เธอใช่มะอันนี้นิ้วนวดอันนี้
ที่หนูมานวดที่นวดหมายหนูสบายไหมเดี๋ยวกู
เห็นหลับนะนวดสบายผู้หญิงมือดีกว่า
เจ็บ
อันนี้เจ็บอ่าของยุงราคาอะๆผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงตัวเองมีอันนี้มีอะไรอีกบนโต๊ะทำงาน
ครูเอ๋
อะไรคะอ่ามีเป็นที่วางบางอะไร
วางโทรศัพท์
ที่วาง
iPad ค่ะ
นะคะมีที่วางโทรศัพท์สาขาครูหญิงไม่มีบน
โต๊ะทำงานไม่มีคุยมีสองแอ่นโอโห้
อันนี้เป็นอะไรคะเป็นเป็นไม้หรออันนี้
เป็นที่วางโทรศัพท์เป็นไม้อันนี้วาง
โทรศัพท์วาง iPad โอเคเป็นพลาสติกแล้วก็
เหล็กเอา
นี่ 2 อันค่ะค่ะพี่น้องผู้หญิงไม่มีค่ะ
แต่ว่าบนโต๊ะทำงานครูหญิงเนี่ยมีมีอะไรวะ
รู้ก่อนนะถ้าครูเห็นไม่เข้าใจให้ดู
ไปหาครูเอ๋อะไรคะ
แก้วน้ำได้เอาก็พูดมากๆ
ขอไม่โอเคต้องดื่มน้ำค่ะ
[เพลง]
บนโต๊ะทำงานครูเอ๋มีแก้วน้ำไหมคะมีค่ะ
แก้วสะทอน
ครูเอ๋บนโต๊ะทำงานครูหญิงมีทิชชู่ด้วยค่ะ
เอกก็มี
วิธีสุดยอด
บนโต๊ะทำงานครูหญิงมีมีสายชาร์จ
คอมพิวเตอร์ใช่มั้ยคอมพิวเตอร์เนี่ยค่ะ
เขามีแค่ไหนก็ต้องมีที่นี่เสียบลงไปซอย
แล้วก็มีสายสายสาย
ค่ะสายชาร์จก็ต้องมีอันนี้ค่ะเครื่องอะไร
ครับครูเอ๋อะไร
รักวิทย์ไฟไฟมืด
อ่าปลั๊กพ่วงารักง่วง
ขอครูเอไม่มีค่ะครูหญิงผู้หญิงต้องเสียบ
คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็เสียบไฟค่ะไปไปอันนี้
ต่างๆก็อยู่บนโต๊ะทำงานค่ะ
และผู้หญิงมีอันนี้ไหมคะผู้หญิงเห็นมีที่
วางโทรศัพท์ของกูเอมีกระดาษ
กระดาษอะไรกระดาษ 8 ค่ะเวลาคู๋
คิด
ช้อปปี้ยังไม่ได้พิมพ์ที่คอมพิวเตอร์คู่
เอกตลาด 8 ขอแนะนำเอากระดาษ post-it หรอ
คะใช่ใหญ่ๆ
ผู้หญิงนี่มั้ยดีค่ะได้ของคู๋ใหญ่ๆอยู่ใน
กล่องใส่ปากกานี่ไงกระดาษ bos  whoami
เยอะโอเคมีสีชมพูสีเขียวสีฟ้า
สีเขียว
แล้วก็มีตรวจการ์ตูนค่ะอันนี้น่ารักค่ะ
แหมไม่ได้
ผู้หญิงก็มีค่ะการ์ตูนค่ะนี่ไงกูหญิงมี
การ์ตูนบนโต๊ะทำงานใช้ไหมการ์ตูนไหนดู
หน่อยจะตายไงตุ๊กตา
วางบนโต๊ะทำงานข้างๆคอมพิวเตอร์
ไม่เอาเอาขวดน้ำออกมาหาแล้วก็มีการ์ตูน
วาง 1 ที่ 2 แวะข้างๆคอมพิวเตอร์
ครูเอ๋ไม่มีนะคะไปเล่นนะคะไว้เล่นและคู่
ami อันนี้นะคะผู้หญิงแต่นะมีอะไรคะบ่น
ว่าจะค่ะได้ค่ะมีเป็น
แบบนี้
เป็นกล่องสี่เหลี่ยมเหรอคะไม่ใช่กล่องค่ะ
หนูเป็นสี่เหลี่ยมเป็นชั้นอ๋อ
งั้น
เท่าๆคอมพิวเตอร์
ชะมัดไซส์เท่ากับคอมพิวเตอร์ค่ะ
ไว้วาง
วางอ่า
เจลล้างเบลอ
วาง
นี่เมียนี้เท่าไหร่คะนี้สำหรับ
คะฉีดที่คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็มีผ้า
ทำความสะอาดเช็ดเช็ดคอมพิวเตอร์
สัญญาณน้ำยาใช่ไหมคนไทยแลกน้ำยา
น้ำยาอัดฉีดเลยทรายค่ะน้ำยาได้ยินเสียง
ไว้แล้วก็เช็คทำยัง
แชทเช็ดน้ำยาเช็ดหน้าจอคอมพิวเตอร์
[เพลง]
โอเคนะก็ฝนตกครูเอ๋เอ๋บนโต๊ะทำงานครูหญิง
ดีปฏิทินด้วยค่ะ
มาก
มีปฏิทินอยู่บนโต๊ะทำงาน
ผู้หญิงไม่ดีก็ไม่รู้นะมีปฏิทินแต่ครูเอ๋
มีไหมคะบนโต๊ะทำงานไม่มีค่ะงูไม่มีแตก
พี่เมย์มีมีอะไรนะ
มีอะไรอีกคะครูเอ๋ครูเอ๋มีอะไรอีกมีเยอะ
ผู้หญิงมีอันนี้ด้วยค่ะกูเอไอเอส
อะไรคะครูเอ๋มีอาจกล่องใส่สีเอาอันนี้
เป็นสีหรอคะสีเมจิกราคาค่ะสิ
บนโต๊ะทำงานครูหญิงก็จะมีกล่องรูปภาพน้อง
กล้องรูปภาพค่ะเวลาเปิด
เปิดกล่องนะคะข้างในก็มีรูปภาพนามิกล่อง
รูปภาพผู้หญิงทำโต๊ะทำงานคู๋มีลิ้นชัก
มีลิ้นชักด้วยนักเรียนจะดูใช่ไหมคะใช้งาน
นักเรียนและครูหญิงอยากดูได้ไหมคะดูไม่
ได้ก็ได้ๆๆโอ้วโอ้ว We ดินชาร์จลิ้นชาร์จ
ในลิ้นชักมีอะไรคะโอเคเอากล้องเก็บก่อน
ได้ค่ะหยิบไอ้หนูในลิ้นชักก็มีกล่องรูป
ภาพเหมือนครูหญิง
ใช่แล้วก็มีอันนี้ค่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋สายวัด
โหหรือมือวัดเอวบ้านวัดแขนก็ได้กูเอ๋ไม่
เป็นไรวัดเอวไปวัดเซลล์อ้าวัดเอวสายวัด
พร้อมเพย์วัดเอวก่อนนะคะอ่านิ้ว
แค่นี้ครูเอ๋
พี่เอ๋วะเร็ว old ครูเอ๋
4  22 นิ้วครูเอลเล็กมากๆไม่ไม่
เป็นไรนักเรียนไม่เห็น
เอกโกหก
โกหกนะคะอาหารใส่วัดนะคะ
ครูเอมมีอันนี้ด้วยในลิ้นชักเหล็กอะไรคะ
พี่เอ๋เทียนหญ้ามีที่เรียน
มีมากๆนะคะไปมั้ยไม่บนโต๊ะทำงานโต๊ะทำงาน
ครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่มีลิ้นชักเหนือแต่โต๊ะทำ
งานครูหญิงยังมีของอีกค่ะครูเอ๋มีอะไรอีก
คะมีหนังสือ
เดี๋ยวๆๆสะดุดมีหนังสือ
หนังสือน่ากลัวไม่น่ากลัวครูเอ๋
ดูหนังหนังสือหรือเหมือนๆ Sherlock
Holmes มีหนังสือด้วยไม่ได้มีหนังสือ
อย่างเดียวนะครูเอ๋มีอะไรมีการ์ตูน
โอ้ยมีการ์ตูนบนโต๊ะทำงานเอกก็มีหนังสือ
ผู้หญิงหนังสืออะไรกันต่างกันแป้งหนังสือ
ครูเอ๋เนี่ยอร่อยไม่น่ากลด
บางทีนะครูหนังสือขนม
หนังสือสนมหมดหรือยังจ๊ะบนโต๊ะทำงานยัง
ค่ะเดี๋ยวนะมันโต๊ะทำงานคู๋มีอะไรอีกผู้
ใดมีอะไรอีกมีไม้บรรทัดต่อสอ
ถ้ามีผ้า
ผ้าเอาไว้ฆ่ากูเช็ดเช็ดโต๊ะเช็ดสมัยโต๊ะ
ก็เช็ดเช็ดๆเช็ดโต๊ะทำงานโต๊ะทำงานคู๋มี
ฟองน้ำทุกตัว
เพิ่งกูเอาไว้ทำอะไรคะไว้ถูถูตัวเองเหรอ
คะไม่ใช่ค่ะ kuai มีคลาสแล้วก็เอาของน้ำ
มาแล้วลืมเอาไปเก็บ
เวลากูอาบน้ำก็เอ้ยแช่งน้ำอยู่ที่ไหน
มีฟองน้ำมี 2  2 น้ำมีฟองน้ำถูตัวฟองน้ำ
ล้างจาน
อันนี้เป็นฟองน้ำถูตัวอันนี้ฟองน้ำล้าง
จานน้ำยาหน้าตาในรักผู้หญิงกินข้าวแล้วมี
จานมีชามไปล้าง
ทำไมซึ่งน้องอันนี้ก็เป็นโต๊ะทำงานค่ะครู
แอบครูเอ๋นะคะกับครูหญิงหน่อยค่ะมีของมาก
ๆได้ไม่รู้นะโต๊ะทำงานนักเรียนมีอะไรนะคะ
ครูหญิงเหมือนครู a ไหมค่ะน้องก็แต่ว่า
วีดีโอนี้เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วนะคะเดี๋ยวเจอ
กันในคลิปหน้าได้หากเจอกันคลิปหน้านะคะ
คลิปนี้จะกินก็คลิปนี้นะ
หายหายของหาที่ไหนที่ไหน
โอเคค่ะแล้วเจอกันใหม่คลิปหน้าค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ
บ๊ายบาย
[เพลง]